we are going to begin with the news and
the News again today is extreme weather
all across the country nearly 90 million
Americans under heat advisories with
triple digit temperatures all the way
from the Pacific to the Atlantic also
the Northeast is still hampered by a
widespread flooding after a storm dumped
two months worth of rain in just two
days and there is now more rain in the
forecast we're going to have full team
coverage this morning but we're going to
start with Meg Oliver who's made her way
to Berry Vermont May good morning to you
we've been talking to you there in
Vermont recently it's a difficult couple
of days for a lot of communities there
that's right Tony good morning to you it
has been a very difficult time for these
residents here in Barrie or about 20
minutes south of the state capitol the
good news flood waters are receding
across the state but the damage is
extensive take a look at this car
dealership behind me where the concrete
buckled almost tossing that jeep into
the river below
Vermont's Capital was underwater Tuesday
as Crews rescued more than 100 people
from submerged cars and homes she's on
the third floor we can't get over there
in downtown Montpelier people kayaked
through the waist-high water thank you
that's how Lena hagenauer was reunited
with her bearded dragon that was left at
home when she evacuated oh she's great
I'm thankful for all the help of the
community honestly I never expected this
in Ludlow Vermont residents are peeking
through the remains of what the
receiving water left behind
more than six inches of rain pummeled
the city in just two days entire roads
turned to Mud this railroad track was
loved dangling across a divide after the
ground under it washed away how high did
the flood waters get the water went
probably I'm I'm 5-11 it was probably
taller than me Andrew mullen's
restaurant Sam's Steakhouse is full of
mud and debris after flooding Monday all
our chairs all over the place tables
flipped it was just told about the
station
it was a mess in there as residents
start that long cleanup process we did
learn overnight that that Dam that was
threatening to overflow has started to
recede so some good news there meanwhile
cleanup crews are beginning this very
long process Eureka yeah glad to see
those waters are finally receding Meg
thank you